let's go to Zagreb with Maurice here has
a special gift it does have a special
guest yeah yes indeed a special guest an
ambassador at that Norway's ambassador
to Croatia
Astrid Vesto welcome to the show Astrid
you must be so tickled to have magnus
carlsen playing in croatia could you
imagine I mean you've been ambassador
here for four years maybe since 2015 I
believe and now you have the world
champion your own world champion here in
Zagreb what does that mean to you
oh it's great I'm read it's so
interesting to follow him and I'm as
ambassador of Norway I'm so proud of the
Magnus Carlsen and that he's in Croatia
is a it's so important to us he's really
a good promoter of Norway my ambassador
himself if you will absolutely he you
played you play the first move today so
you were honored with that as well and
you have brought a staff to watch the
games as well yeah we are four people
from the embassy we are a very small
embassy we are only two diplomats and we
have six local stuff but we are four
here today of course to follow of -
Carson and also to see how how because
we used to watch it on television and
it's great to see it live actually
seeing him here playing very well as a
matter of fact as he's lighting up the
whole Jess world tell us the importance
of the relationship between between
Norway and Croatia what kind of work do
you do what kind of relationship do you
have business and otherwise first of all
I would like to say that we have very
good relationship with Croatia we have
absolutely no outstanding issues so we
are friends and we have so much in
common they are both coastal states with
a huge marine and my time tradition and
we have business cooperation we
corporation within culture within
education and not at least to mention
the interest from the region to come to
crash as tourists I think this year it
would be around 300 thousand origin
theories coming to Croatia it had been
direct flights from nine different
airports in Norway seven days a week and
you know we are only five million people
so it seems like a lot of them are
coming to Croatia
I imagine the beaches in Croatia are a
little bit warmer than those in Norway
you are a little bit Magnus I mentioned
him being an ambassador he must just a
much as help only help to have him here
with even the Prime Minister
Andre plane kovitch coming to the
opening ceremony that highlights one of
the importance of chess of course but
also Magnus is presence of course on it
the interest for chess has increased
dramatically the last years in Norway
that's also thanks to Magnus and I must
say I was very proud when I saw Prime
Minister plank of each and mungus cards
and I opened the whole tournament them
that was a great great time for me as
ambassador absolutely a real moment
opening with the first first move if you
will great relationship between Norway
and Croatia keep up the great work and I
know you're enjoying watching the young
man's do his thing here again the
ambassador of Norway to Croatia Astrid
their stove which she tells me it's
perfect pronunciation by the way it is
thank you once as you can tell they're
very proud of Magnus Carlsen thank you